what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I've been thinking about this
for the last couple days or so on like
making up a story because it's been a
long time since we made up a story and I
feel like I feel like we kind of need to
because it's been a little while so and
this one we're gonna make up a story on
the the Hulk who laughs like Joker Hulk
and of course this is based on a Batman
who lost but the idea of the of like the
Joker becoming the Incredible Hulk
sounds so awesome but like it could
unfold in like a myriad of different
ways okay so so here's a way here's a
way I see this alright here's the way I
see this going down so so one we'd have
to explain how it is that Joker becomes
the Hulk right and I mean it's coming
book so we can just kind of do whatever
we want to do like we could say for
example that like in this alternate DC
universe that Marvel Comics exists as
actual comic books they buy and read so
like the Joker knows who Captain America
is in comic books because he's been
reading Captain America comics in
spider-man or something like that but
let's say that like for whatever reason
the Joker like seemed clip oh no okay
The Joker like see Incredible Hulk
because the Incredible Hulk is chaos
right like The Incredible Hulk is
pandemonium like whenever it is the Hulk
goes on like a rampage there's no
telling what's gonna happen and like the
Joker loves that element he likes the
idea that like The Incredible Hulk some
predictable and so the Joker is like I
want to become the Incredible Hulk and
so by whatever manner and whatever means
uses all his money resources or whatever
and basically like imitates the gamma
bomb experiment and so the result is
that Joker is transformed in the
Incredible Hulk now here's the thing we
can't really do like savage whole I mean
we could but it would take away from the
story I would think cuz I think it'd be
an easier to story to tell if we said
that like we get basically professor
home where it's like the Joker in the
Incredible Hulk merged into a singular
person or like they're kind of like a
singular being but like it's the
unlimited strength of the Incredible
Hulk with like the mind of the Joker
like that would that would be absolutely
amazing so like we would have a Whitney
go with like this virgin Incredible Hulk
was just green because I mean the Joker
you know it's green purple and red so we
could just go with what em and white so
we can go with like the green Hulk maybe
he has green hair maybe has like you
know the the Joker lipstick on or
whatever it is but like he's basically
Joker eyes like that'd be the coolest
thing ever but here's where I think the
story would get cool
now here's what I think we will get
awesome so we could say that because the
fact that this is the Incredible Hulk
with the Joker's mind
dude we can see the Joker kind of got a
little bit smarter right because like by
and large and in DC Comics the Joker
just like does things right like he just
does stuff like Heath Ledger's Joker
quoted it perfectly I'm just a dog
chasing cars I
know what to do if I caught one so
that's basically how the Joker works in
DC Comics I mean he can be really really
smart like he was a new 52 Batman but
let's say that like in this instance
instead of just saying like I want to
just go smash stuff alright he's like
we're gonna play this out intelligently
so what he does is he takes the approach
of Dane now for those are guys who don't
know Bane of course god is like huge
claim to fame during nightfall he came a
year after bat I'm sorry after Superman
died people say they weren't really
connected I really believe they were
because Superman dying was such a huge
thing in publicity they were like listen
listen take away Batman
let's break Batman's back we can't
really kill him but let's break his back
and then have somebody else take his
place and so um so what ended up
happening is DC introduced Bane and Bane
was a guy where he essentially was like
he was enamored by the bat of Gotham
City like you know this this you know
kind of mythical figure that existed out
there and it essentially just like
gained control of the city like you know
getting control of the criminal element
and like for the most part kept
criminals like suppressed and so because
he was more of like a mythological being
in vane one of the challenge Bane travel
to Gotham City and in like three or four
months figured out the identity of
Batman he was like yeah so like Batman's
Bruce Wayne okay cool so let's take him
out so then like he broke Batman's back
but it was it was a long time coming it
was like shadow games and stuff like
that it was like he would pop up and
then like Todd Batman and then leave
like he would just show up every once in
a while and so like the Joker would do
that right like the Joker would sit down
and say okay we're gonna consolidate
power like that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna consolidate all my power in
Gotham City and then I'll take out
Batman because I don't want anybody to
get to Batman before I do but he
wouldn't do it all at once it wouldn't
be like all in one night right like you
just be like shadow games and stuff like
that and so what he would do is he would
he would say okay I'm gonna take out the
penguin and so like the Penguins
defeated and then you don't hear from
him for like another month and a half or
two months and that's why Batman can't
find him because like when Batman cuz
never would figure out something's going
on pretty quickly I would imagine that
they would probably probably say like
okay this is like another vigilante
because like the Joker can turn back
into himself it will he can like become
the the Joker iced Hulk or just turn
back into regular Joker and that's what
he does like you chill he'll turn into
like Joker eyes Hulk and then I take out
the penguin and then go back to his
normal self and then do his regular
schemes and Batman's none the wiser
Batman hasn't figured out what's going
on and so because he pops up so
infrequently Batman's just kind of like
I'm not really sure where this guy's out
or what's going on is he like a
vigilante is he trying to help me is he
an enemy is he trying to conquer the
city like Batman wouldn't really know
what's happening and so this would go on
for the better part of like a year right
like it'd be like a month and a half
after Joker's dead and I'm
they're penguins dead and then Joker
would kill to face and then like three
months would pass and then Joker would
kill like the Riddler and like what he
would do is he would literally like
consolidate all the henchmen and stuff
like that but the hitch would all go
into the guise of like the Hulk right
and so like Batman's idea is okay maybe
it's like the whole crew laughs is like
just this army of people is all it is
they call themselves the Hulk because
they're like a hulking number of people
the Batman couldn't quite figure it out
and so eventually what would happen is
like all the villains in Gotham City
would be destroyed except for the Joker
and then that's when Batman would
finally figure out the Joker is like the
Hulk who lasts because he's the only one
that hasn't been taken out yet and and
hasn't been like killed the Joker would
set it up so that like his own bases had
been targeted and it seems like they'd
been hit and different things like that
to throw Batman off the trail but then
from there like Batman would say okay so
like he would find like he'd face off
against the the the whole crew laughs
and like it would be it would be like
just an absolute bloodbath like it would
be a murdering like that I wouldn't die
but he would get his his his backside
handed to him quite readily
so like Batman gets totally decimated by
the whole cool a scene he's like okay I
need backup here now remember this is
this is Joker with the incredible Hulk's
unlimited strength but it's not like
just unlimited at the outset right like
he has to get angrier in order to get
stronger and so like what they need is a
catalyst like what we need for this
story is a catalyst to piss them off in
order like set his powers in motion so
what would happen is Batman would go to
the Justice League and say I need help
with this I can't defeat this guy on my
own and so what would happen from there
is like they would all basically meet up
a man would say like here's everything
that's going on here's everything that's
happening here's everything I've learned
but Batman has learned that like the
Joker gets stronger the angrier he gets
and so he would basically tell Superman
he looked like when we go into this
fight you're on a ticking clock you
cannot let this fight drag on too long
if you do he will get stronger than you
and he will destroy you and so it's just
like like they going about NASA got like
this great huge plan and let's say it's
like the classic roster of the Justice
League right so like Green Lantern Hal
Jordan the flash Barry Allen
Wonder Woman's Superman Batman and like
for good measure um maybe Martian
Manhunter but I kind of like keeping
into those five like those are those
core five people flash freelancer and
Wonder Woman Batman Superman like I like
keeping it at those five so like they
show up and and that's that's the
catalyst that sets the Joker off because
it because like one thing always
remember the Joker is basically in love
with Batman is always the idea that like
the fights they engage in that's like
the Batman Joker dance it's like this is
our dance no one's allowed to be in our
dance and so when Batman is like
bringing other people and it's like it's
like it's like Jack Nicholson Joker
right he's like another rooster in the
henhouse like that's basically what
happens
there's you know like they show up and
the Joker gets pissed because he's like
you you totally destroyed this this is
supposed to be our dance
and so like that's what sets off his
anger and so like as soon as the justice
league shows up and like the Joker
starts getting pissed off the clock
starts and like Superman's facing off
against like you know the the whole crew
laughs as best he can for as long as you
can everybody else is there - right like
Wonder Woman's getting shots and she's
like sending him flying you know and
like the flash Barry Allen's doing his
whole thing you know doing you know
running around and like trying to punch
him you know all I kind of kind of good
stuff and Batman's like the brains
behind the operation right like Batman's
like hey look do this do that you know
and so on and so forth like trying to
figure out a way to power this guy down
and so like as the fight begins to
stretch on the Joker begins to realize
what's happening that like they're
trying to take him out as fast as
possible to make sure he doesn't get so
strong that he can out match them all
and so what he does is he actually like
jumps away like jumps to Metropolis or
something like that right work is like
Superman is like the main threat while
he's like the powerhouse he's like the
formidable threat so super elite like
jumps away and like travels to
Metropolis like doomsday did and then
just starts like tearing apart the Daily
Planet and like goes like knocks the
building down to the foundation and just
sends it like crashing down and so like
Superman has to race in and save who we
can in Batman's like no no you have to
let him die you have to let him die we
have to stop like hope you know whole
crew lasts because if we don't more
people will die if Superman's like I
don't care I'm not letting Lois Lane and
Jimmy Olsen died it's like he flies into
the Daily Planet and like in the time it
takes him to like rescue them the
strength of the Joker has surpassed
Superman so Superman comes back in and
he's just getting like jests I made it
and like if Superman's getting decimated
Wonder Woman is getting decimated and
like we can't be given throw-in Shazam
and say like Shazam's getting decimated
we can just say like he showed up
because whatever the old man the old
wizard told him to go said hey go boy
like these are getting crazy man go he's
just like shows like I am and he shows
up and fights and then like like Barry
Allen has this idea right at Barry
Allen's like hey I have an idea I have a
way we you know that we can beat him and
Batman's like what is he's like I'll do
the infinite mass punch there's like no
no no no that's Wally's move Wally knows
how to do the infinite massed punch you
don't Barry's like yeah well he's not
here so I got this man so like a so as
that man's like no no no don't do that
man don't do that it's not gonna work
it's not gonna work and there's like no
man I got this we like races around the
world like three times right and then
just like comes running up on like the
whole cool ass and like hits him with
the infinim a sponge is like infinite
mass aren't you like hits him and it
just like staggers him and that man's
like oh my god right it's like L press
the dorset and then sandy ravaged live
commentary you didn't beat him you just
pissed him off and now you know that's
all I saw like like Batman's banners
all right dude you totally screwed us
over like like like he's so pissed like
he's way more pissed now than he was
before so like we're basically doomed
like we're facing off against this guy
with an incalculable level of strength
who's already insane and then in turn
like has defeated pretty much all of the
Justice League and me as Batman I'm the
last man standing so having said all
that this is your all's turn I want you
guys to tell me how this story ends
because I always said you're trying to
think of an ending and I couldn't think
of a good one like I'd kind of written
myself into a hole right like I'm like
in like I'm in my Shyamalan I can't just
I can't write a good story uh well at
least I couldn't write a good story for
like seven years and then I wrote split
which was an amazing movie
what like anyway let me know what you
guys think like like give me give me the
ending of this story down in the comment
section I really want to know what you
guys come up with like I'm really
excited to see how you guys in this but
if you guys are new here to come as
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later purse
[Music]
you